the baggage that men carry if the older  they get as well means they either been  in sales for longer or they've [ __ ]  around for longer so those two bring two  problems either you're going to be  insecure and think that you cannot trust  any woman because you've been with too  many three or fours or you're going to  be very insecure in yourself and in your  manhood because you've not had enough  experience so men have the insecurities  and they have their baggage that's why  you'd rather be with somebody that's  somewhere on your level because it's  easier for both of you to carry the  scents  I agree with you what yeah they're you  agree with me yeah some men have baggage  some women have baggage